convierte 51.8 decímetros a kilómetros
muy bien tenemos que entender cómo son
los decímetros y los kilómetros con
respecto a los metros así que déjame
empezar con los decímetros tenemos 51.8
lo voy a copiar aquí 51.8 decímetros de
100 metros decímetros y lo que vamos a
hacer es primero pasar estos decímetros
a metros para realizar esta conversión
necesitamos multiplicar aquí por metros
metros
y dividir entre decímetros le voy a
poner aquí de 100 metros de metros y
estamos haciendo esto para que las
unidades queden correctas para que los
decímetros se cancelen y nos quede en
metros y ahora debemos poner cuántos
decímetros hay en cada metro y el
prefijo de si quiere decir una décima
parte
esto es una décima parte una décima
parte de esta forma una décima parte de
metro es un decímetro lo voy a poner así
una décima parte que también podemos
pensarlo como si podemos pensarlo como
que en cada metro hay diez decímetros
muy bien entonces que nos queda esto
esto es igual a decímetros se cancela
con decímetros tenemos que hacer 51.8
entre diez pero eso es lo mismo que
dividir entre 10 o sea recorrer el punto
decimal una unidad hacia la izquierda de
esta forma nos queda 5.18 metros
metros muy bien ya que tenemos esto a
metros ahora vamos a pasarlo a
kilómetros voy a copiar esto aquí abajo
son 5.18 18 metros me tros muy bien y
ahora queremos pasar esto a kilómetros
de forma que necesitamos que en el
numerador aparezcan kilómetros lo voy a
poner aquí kilómetros
y en el denominador para que se cancele
esta unidad queremos que quede metros
metros muy bien entonces ahora qué
quiere decir kilómetros el prefijo kilo
kilo quiere decir mil entonces un
kilómetro son mil metros lo ponemos aquí
uno entre mil o bien podemos pensar que
una milésima parte de un kilómetro es un
metro muy bien vamos a realizar este
producto a ver qué nos queda esto de
aquí es igual a esto de aquí es igual a
metros se cancela con metros nos queda
kilómetros las unidades kilómetros
y los metros
y ahora debemos hacer 5 puntos 18 entre
mil y 5 puntos 18 entre 1000 y para
hacer esta división basta recorrer el
punto decimal varias veces verdad si
tuviéramos déjame déjame ponerlo aquí a
la izquierda en color naranja si
tuviéramos 5.18 18 entre 10
esto sería recorrer el punto decimal un
lugar hacia la izquierda nos quedaría
0.5 18 si tuviéramos 5.18 dividido entre
100 tendríamos que recorrer el punto
decimal dos lugares hacia la izquierda
esto sería igual a cero punto un lugar
queda aquí y con otro lugar queda aquí
un cero verdad entonces sería 0.05 18 y
finalmente si debemos dividir entre 1000
5.18 dividido entre 1.200 a ver vamos a
poner el 5 punto 18 o el 5 18
518 el punto decimal está aquí y tenemos
que recorrer los tres lugares hacia la
izquierda aquí sería uno luego serían
dos aquí aparece un cero y luego tres
aquí aparece otro cero y el punto
decimal queda aquí de esta forma la
respuesta es lo voy a poner aquí que
esto es igual a es igual a 0.00 518 km
los metros y siempre es bastante bueno
revisar que las cuentas tengan sentido
mira aquí estamos pasando de decímetros
a metros y metros es una unidad más
grande tiene sentido que haya disminuido
el número pues sí sí tenemos una cierta
cantidad de unidades pequeñas esa es una
menor cantidad de unidades más grandes
por eso tiene sentido dividir entre 10 y
que nos quede un número más chico y de
manera similar si aquí tenemos 5.18 y
ahora pasamos a kilómetros que son una
unidad todavía más grande tiene sentido
que obtengamos bien poquitos kilómetros
sale o sea que 5.18 disminuya al pasar a
una unidad mayor